- The fact that muffins have
more calories than
doughnuts blows my mind.
It's density.
Super interesting stuff.
(light music)
I think college is in real,
real interesting,
in a real interesting
place and 20, 30 years.
I just think they're starting to
get exposed for the
businesses they are.
I aggressively, you're about to
hear aggressively like being way
more open to non-college degrees
and alternative paths and
I think once businesses start
hiring in a different way people
go to college to get a job.
And fun and fine but
a lot of people do.
It will be interesting.
I'm fascinated by college
in 30, 40 year window.
Everybody knows
what's going on but a lot of
companies, the rules and I think
that's what happens in other
places around innovation.
The rules say go conservative.
(censored) still
thinks print first.
I mean, and they're like
struggling to get 25 year old
women and they're like baffled.
Running, can't wait to run
outside and go to the corner
store and get a magazine?
Fired up. Fired up.
Can't wait to go home and hope
the new Elle magazine
is there, right?
You know?
So common sense just doesn't
have a place in business
and that's the opportunity.
Alright guys, have a great day.
Great seeing you.
Have a great day.
- [Ivy] It's been incredible
coming here because I've learned
more in the last two years than
I probably learned in the last
eight years before that.
I love this place.
- Yep, you just don't know if
you want to be a creative lead.
- [Ivy] Yeah. That's literally--
- Makes a lot of sense.
- [Ivy] I'm facing right now.
- I think if as long there's no
major limbo period where you're
just floating in outer space
as you find your way, right?
- [Ivy] Yeah, yeah.
And I don't think that by that's
by any stretch that's what
you're asking, I think how do we
figure out what else you could
be doing in a
place you love,--
- [Ivy] Yeah.
- what else could that be?
I'm glad that Claude got us
together because now, these are
the things that her and I will
talk about. In three weeks,
I'll be on a call on the way to
the airport and be like,
"What's going on," and we'll be
like we'll talk for
10 minutes about you.
I don't think people get that.
- [Ivy] No.
- I wouldn't expect
them to think that.
Do you know what I mean?
- [Ivy] Yeah, yeah.
- You're going to need
to take some initiative.
I think having the cafeteria
and the serendipity that this
company's starting to create
a little bit more of is a great
timing for you.
I think more than ever you need
to cut 15 to 30 minutes out of
every day and say
hello to people.
What do you do?
Speaking to Claude and I is
the right move to put you on the
radar for when we're
thinking about it.
- [Ivy] That's great.
- Otherwise, you wake up and you
hear Ricky Magoo and Sally have
been announced this thing you're
like, "Fuck, that's exactly
what I wanted to do."
- [Ivy] Yeah. That's why
I felt like I had to talk.
- Smart, smart.
Good, I need to
run to a meeting.
- [Ivy] Yeah, yeah.
Thank you so much.
- Great to see you.
Have a great week.
- Great to see you too, you too.
- Ping me any other time.
- I will.
- Awesome.
- [Ivy] Thank you.
- [Woman] Okay.
- [Driver] 535th?
- [Gary] See ya, DRock.
See ya.
- [Man] Yeah, we're
designing it for work.
- [Gary] That is the greatest
thing I've ever seen.
Can you guys please make my
face and just have it there?
- [Man 2] Just a
giant Gary face?
- [Gary] I think you should just
make a bunch of my faces and
just put me on all of them.
I should be on every team.
Yeah, I want my face.
Mix me in.
Those are the stupidest things.
Can we take them down?
I want them down.
- [DRock] They're
like burned on.
- [Gary] I don't
care, unburn 'em.
- [Man 3] No, they're not.
Sticker.
- [Gary] Get them
the fuck out of here.
They're so stupid.
They mean nothing to me.
Okay? I'm right.
- I love it. Yeah.
- You agree?
- I agree.
- Put some fuckin'
Jets jerseys up there.
Andrew, Andrew you're
in charge of that wall.
Get back to me.
That's fucking
bullshit fuckin' yellow.
No, not this one.
We're fuckin'
taking that shit down.
That stuff is garbage.
What the fuck does that mean?
Nate?
- You know what else is garbage?
- [Gary] What?
- These blankets, too.
- [Gary] Yeah, these
fucking bullshit ass
Snapchat Packer blankets.
But those we got to keep.
- Terrible blankets.
- [Gary] Yeah, but
that shit makes no.
Look up Phil, look how stupid
Phil looks walking by that.
(laughter)
Nate. Go take it
down right now.
This is good.
More propaganda about
me, that makes sense.
Fuckin' yellow
squiggly line, stupid.
You still Skye at least 'cause
I don't want to hurt her
feelings before you
to but then do it.
- [Tyler] Skye!
- Skye!
Scott, I'm taking down these
yellow fuckin' squiggly lines.
- [Scott] Oh, the lines?
- [Gary] That's a stupidest
shit I've ever seen.
It means nothing.
- What are they?
- [Gary] Skye, I'm taking
down these yellow squigglys.
- [Skye] What yellow squigglys?
- [Gary] The fucking cube
three-dimensional horse shit.
- [Skye] That was mean
but I'll take them down.
- No, no I'm definitely
taking them down.
Nate's already taking them
down but I just like you.
- [Skye] What, you
don't like them?
- [Gary] No, I don't them.
I don't feel like
they mean anything.
To me.
- They're shapes.
- [Gary] Yeah, Nate's
taking them down.
And Andrew is now
in charge of it.
He'll come back with a plan.
- [Skye] Okay.
- [Gary] I just wanted you to
know when you walk by and be
like, "Where's my cubes?"
That was you, right?
- [Skye] No, it wasn't.
- Who's is it?
Who wanted it?
Got it. Okay, good.
Babcock and his
fuckin' yellow propaganda.
I'll tell you right now
we're going to stop this yellow
propaganda of Babcock's.
(group laughter)
- [Skye] I like the yellow.
You don't like the yellow?
- Skye, be careful.
(applause)
We will overcome.
- [Man 4] Gary, what's all
this yellow doing over here?
- There's so much
fucking yellow.
It's fucking Babcock's
bullshit agenda.
We're going to overthrow
him. He's finished.
- [Man 5] What was on the
wall that you tore down?
- [Gary] There was
like some cube shit.
I don't know.
Nate, I'm really proud of you.
- I feel like it's the best
thing I've done in a while.
- [Gary] I think it's the best
thing you've ever done
for this company.
I'm really pumped we're here.
Basically, the punch line is
I want to get into
a better cadence
especially with the few
individuals that look like you
that actually want to do shit
but I want to do them, the way
we texted is kind of how
I want to go about it which is
something new comes out that's
meaningful I want to understand
if we can shoot for the moon and
then the reality of the brand,
the current climate within the
organization or the financial
barriers, does that make me
land on the mountain and is the
mountain worth climbing, right?
That's kind of how I'm thinking.
Report cards on the way?
I'm so fuckin' pumped.
- [Tyler] Your girl Vivian
from the counselor's
office this morning.
- I'm so fucking fired up.
So what?
- They're gonna send it here.
- All four years?
- Yeah.
(group laughter)
- Do you know I've been having a
recurring, this is a true story,
that I've been having a
recurring dream for 20 years
that I don't graduate high
school like they tell me
you didn't do it.
You didn't graduate,
you can't walk.
And now I weirdly think that
they may look at these and
be like wait a minute.
(group laughter)
I might be opening up a can
of worms that I do not
want to deal with.
(light music)
Hug it out.
I like hugging.
How are you? Good?
- [Jessa] Good.
- All good stuff?
- [Jessa] Yeah.
- Yes, I know.
What is he?
- Flustered about
his assignment.
- Sounds like he's
a losing player.
Listen, my intuition,
I'm winning twice.
We got rid of the fuckin'
geometric and Andrew G.
This is perfect.
- [Emily] Wait, Andrew's gone?
What just happened?
- [Man 6] I thought you
talked to Skye first.
- Dude, totally don't worry.
Don't worry.
You know I'm joking, right?
It's just like Sid,
is Sid here? No.
- [Emily] He's right there.
(laughter)
- [Gary] No, no he doesn't
have to talk to Skye.
I told Skye that I took it down
and then I just am waiting for
Andrew to give me some
information on what he
thinks we should put there.
- [Emily] Wait, Andrew's
an interior designer now?
- [Gary] He's worried about it?
- The pressure.
- [Gary] He's a serious kid,
he's great. I can't wait.
He can draw, he can paint,
I don't know.
Yeah, that's super fine.
I'm fine with that.
I just didn't want the
fuckin' squiggly lines.
- [Emily] Really is it
because they were neon?
- Hey Facebook, it's me
Gary but you know that.
This is my team, lots of
them, all very attractive.
Great hair, Zak. Ty.
This is my crew.
This is my crew, right?
We're doing context,
what time is it?
- [Group] 8:30.
- [Gary] 8:30.
There's my team.
Lots of people.
Just to give you, trying to
give you some context here.
Here's the overall office thing.
We're just going to
do a little tour.
We're just a look at
density in the office.
My crew.
Sid. Very happy.
Sid's here.
My crew. Right?
Now, let's just go walk around.
No, no, no.
Let's see this block, finance.
Nope. Looks like
no bills will be paid.
HR, recruiting, no.
Looks like an 0-for-50.
Kitchen.
Yes, great work.
- Always hustling.
- [Gary] I love it brother.
Alright, a little bit there.
A little hustle there, not bad.
Yes.
Shoots, I'm very impressed.
No, I'm just doing a little live
stream based on the density of
my team at the office which
is very full this is just the
entire wing over here, hundreds
of people nobody
but Shoots, Anna.
Anna you made a
Snapchat appearance today.
- I did.
- [Gary] Were you
excited about that?
- I was very excited about that.
- [Gary] Shoots, very nice.
Okay.
I think we should go
downstairs, right?
Can I go through here?
- [DRock] I think so.
- [Gary] Alright.
Let's see.
We're still good.
Hope you guys are super well.
Okay.
- [DRock] Here.
- [Gary] Okay.
DRock, help me.
- [DRock] Don't pull.
- [Gary] Got it, awesome.
Got it. Oh, Marcus.
You know what,
you're the best Marcus.
I'm just going around the office
showing how full my team was,
we were all there.
- (inaudible) has a
lot of people there.
- [Gary] Is there?
- Well, most the
senior people are there.
- [Gary] That's very good.
Yes. Great job, Chase.
Very impressed.
A good percentage.
Just going around the office.
(group chatter)
- Of course we're here.
- [Gary] You guys are hustling.
Very good, I'm very happy.
All right, nope, none here.
Very good, Ryan
with his new haircut.
Good separation.
What up, my man?
Very nice.
Look at Loomis,
holding it down.
Gesualdi, OG's very good.
Alright, very nice.
Good percentage, I'm
proud of this downstairs.
You should've seen some of
the pockets upstairs, Gesualdi.
- [Gesualdi] Complete deserts?
- [Gary] Deserts.
- [Gesualdi] No hustle deserts.
- [Gary] No hustle, kinda
like your fantasy baseball team.
- [Gesualdi] Fair.
(group laughter)
- [Gary] Love it.
And that was the hustle tour.
Alright DRock, I'm outta here.
Well, this is
going to be exciting.
A lot of you talk
about too much content.
I'm pounding you
with too much content.
Well, good news.
I'm going off the grid for
two and a half, three weeks.
Now, I'll be back to nice and
quiet. They'll be some old stuff
that other Tyler
creates and finds.
You think that's funny, Staphon?
You're gonna have to
find some shit too.
- I know.
(group laughter)
Hope you guys have
a great end of summer.
We'll be back with vengeance.
I'm going to be on the
west coast right away.
We'll send DRock out there
because I gotta make
Jets predictions.
We'll be right into
football season
the second I see you again.
Little family downtime for next
two and a half, three weeks.
Enjoy and I will
talk to you guys soon.
(light music)